bonjour soraya vitaux la merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france pour parler de la situation
en colombie où d'ailleurs on n'a plus
aucune image depuis depuis plusieurs
jours
là les connexions internet ont été
coupés dans le pays merci a vous d
autres invitations
effectivement on by ya pas d
informations sur internet
apparemment les socios sont coupées sont
bloqués justement pour éviter la
communication et live sur la situation
qui est autour des patients coloris sur
qui ont cessé ce sont les vidéos qui on
reçoit sur les oiseaux des amis et de la
famille qui y restons colombie au port
on tourne de loin tout ce qui se passe
là bas
est-ce que les manifestations se
poursuivent ce matin et hier soit en
tout cas on il ya un décalage horaire il
est minuit là bas est-ce que les
manifestations se sont poursuivies et la
répression également justement c'est
pour ça que c'est couper la
communication parce qu' elle ne voulait
pas montrer la réalité des chaussons
colombie l'été les manifestations sont
toujours au corps et maintenant ça c'est
très fort c'est parce que la force
publique et commence à exercer sa force
justement sur le sol de la communauté
indigène qui est cette dure en premier
ligne sur la manifestation de colombie
qu'est ce qui se passe en colombie cette
manifestation et ça se développe
toujours parce que depuis de soissons
vicent des injustices des disparitions
forcées des disparitions des leaders
sociaux et des services viennent de la
réforme à la santé qui est ton vis à
dire primat qui sait la santé justement
de la sécurité les gens n'ont plus c'est
la troisième celle à trois tiers est
format fiscale qui est l'état essaye de
mettre en place pendant la pandémie
c'était une pétition un peu pas mal hein
donc les gens m'ont dit et les virus
s'est pas trop danger pour l'état donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont toujours
manifesté à bien hop un obama day notre
eau notre droit dans quoi et on va
arrêter on va demander au nez sur les
[ __ ] à l'eau nous a tous les
communauté internationale ou ou pour
qu'elle fasse quelque chose face à la
violence à la violence extrême
cette violence extrême que vous décrivez
elle se manifeste comment on a parlé de
policiers qui tiraient à balles réelles
sur les manifestants c'est exact tout à
fait ça c'est tout à fait ça les gens
manifestent mais et ils sont pas les
moyens d'avoir c'est c'est la violence
et aux guerres internes à quillan
colombie comme vous pouvez regarder sous
les sous les images et voilà c'est clair
sur ce que vous voyez ici passer la
police c'est l'esma qui tirent contre la
pop culture à la population colombienne
contre le couple colombienne de cette
façon c'est quelque chose quand tu as le
il y a eu une condamnation de la part du
venezuela ce week end est ce qu'il y à
d'autres condamnations des etats-unis
notamment qui sont un allié de la
colombie en fait aux états unis magog au
fait il a il a parlé aussi
il s'exprimait sur les vidéos qu'ils y
assure et sur les internets sur internet
et sur les amis colombiens qui reçoit
aussi donc il n'est pas d'accord avec la
violence sur les manifestations et des
abus des abus de la police est en train
là
les gens qui sont pas armés donc il ya
déjà des gens qui sont décédés à courte
et cette violence et a suivi comment ça
veut dire qu'ils n'ont pas à aider à la
force armée d'économies parce qu'ils
sont pas comment ça va se terminer on
parle déjà d'une révolution en colombie
c'est le cas selon vous je pense que la
génération d'aujourd'hui sont très
fortes et ils savent qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent ils disent si ces panneaux
bijoux ce qui va nous tous et ça sert à
l'état donc on y va je pense que les
gens sont a marre de toute la situation
qui en colombie que vous avez vous dire
tout à l'heure c'est pas seulement
contrôler réforme fiscale qui passe d'un
5 % à 19 % ou les gens mort des défunts
il ya des gens qui selon le le
département administratif des
statistiques il ya 21 millions de
pauvres hop et des gens pauvres et 7.4
millions de pauvreté extrême
ça veut dire qu'ils habitent avec 3 30
euros par mois et le smic en colombie
pour vous montrer un peu le contexte le
smic en colombie c'est à peu près des
224 euros et les sénateurs robbie gagne
1,10 euro symbolique 40 fois plus que la
population en colombie dont que les gens
visés y en a marre on va voir qu'est-ce
qui s'adonnaient le petit dont il a vidé
le faire ou dialogue mais c'est pas
toujours ça le saura y habitent là
qu'est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
à la communauté internationale pour
venir en aide au peuple colombien jours
l'intervention pour aider ou chaque
publie les droits humains en colombie où
que ça termine les cie les inégalités en
colombie et qui est tout le monde soit
tranquille qui n'existait pas déjà vu
des là les abus de la police
quito pas mettre la réforme de la santé
en fait et vous privatiser tout est d'un
très beau et où il devait prononcer à
faire ou bp on a le droit de vivre
tranquille on en a le droit d avoir un
gouvernement qui sait pas aujourd'hui le
cas pour merci beaucoup
donc merci beaucoup sur aia appel
entendu merci se rallia vitaux l'a donc
sur la situation catastrophique en
colombie ce matin